okay before I do anything else today I
want to take a second to thank all of
you who have supported the Rubin report
since we went independent back in June
that goes for all of you who watch
engage with and share our videos but
especially for those of you who have
donated to the Rubin report via patreon
or PayPal almost 3000 of you can proudly
consider yourselves producers of this
show you not only give us the monthly
budget to continue the Rubin report
every week but you also keep the show
free for everybody else this show based
on big ideas and honest conversations
talking to people who I both agree with
and disagree with is really just at the
beginning of what we can do as our own
production company we've got some big
plans and I'll explain those in just a
second the way we produce the Rubin
report right now is with nothing between
me and you the audience
there's no producer screaming in my ear
telling me what to say and there's no
corporate overlord
telling me what to do I truly wouldn't
trade this intellectual freedom for a
million-dollar contract on CNN so with
this in mind we've decided to take the
final step into becoming fully truly
independent over the past few weeks our
production company took out a major loan
to build a home studio life's about
taking risks we've already taken a
couple of them and we figured why not
take one more once we fully build this
studio out which is happening as we
speak
we'll be able to shoot whenever we want
for however long we want this will give
the Rubin Report incredible flexibility
not only to shoot more shows every week
but also to do more collaborations with
people you know and love hosts real
debates on polarizing topics and come up
with new ideas for segments on the fly
ultimately the best way to share these
ideas of free speech and honest
conversation is for me to be beholding
to nobody but you the fans that's really
the beauty of what's going on here you
guys have helped us grow and share this
message across the globe I genuinely
love connecting with our patrons every
month via our private google hangouts
the patreon group chat our exclusive
live streams and more beyond that I'm
amazed and awed at how many of you guys
are connecting with each other and
starting their own blogs or YouTube
channels or just bringing these
conversations to your dinner table so
for those of you who aren't patrons yet
this is your chance to become a producer
of the Reuben report and help us hit our
next goals
so we're serious about growing the show
and fast we'll be starting to do two
interviews per week beginning next week
yep
double the content immediately help us
hit our next goals on patreon and the
show will grow as much as you want it to
everything we're doing at the Rubin
report is because you've enabled us to
continue to do it I hate to sound corny
but you make me a better man speaking of
better people my producer David and my
head of production Amira are seriously
the best team in the business these are
truly the hardest-working people in the
biz and more importantly they never yell
at me for tweeting too much together we
can do this show for a year for roughly
the same cost as one episode of a cable
news show we weren't expecting to make
this move so quickly but the timing
really is perfect the media landscape is
changing so fast and our true
independence will be the key to growing
not only the show but a real political
movement the election is absolute proof
that we need to tackle difficult topics
and controversial ideas honestly most
people don't want the endless fighting
we've become accustomed to but we're the
ones who have to fight to be heard the
most this is my call to action to all of
you not only can you help keep this
message alive but you can help grow it
with no outside influence and with
nothing between us
all right so if you've heard me and you
feel what I feel jump over to patreon
combin report or rubin report comm /
donate and check out our next goals and
some of the plans we have to grow the
Rubin report and if you don't have the
means right now then I hope you'll just
keep watching and sharing our videos in
short the future of the human
civilization is up to you I hope you'll
join us for this wild ride